man klickt jungen alter ich sagte ich
das war die knappste entscheidung meines
lebens
willkommen zu einer neuen folge quick
fire games das hat gut gefallen jetzt
mal deswegen denke ich mir da und es
aber nochmal heute mit dabei die zwei
amtlichen un söhne pascal von dem lack
und logo von logo argumentation weise
und bitte danke gott als alter ich lasse
die treppe hoch erfolgt
das zweite hebt ihn so in die luft ich
drehe mich um
er fliegt über mich hinweg
das macht das leben
wer bist du denn so langsam könnte
eigentlich ein bisschen was ihr davon
haltet mal jemand was ihr davon haltet
ich finde eigentlich ja nicht der sinn
der sache wenn es geht dann ist aber
auch nicht mit ein herz hast nicht drauf
mit einem gegner zugehen hast dich
traurig aber noch 218 direkte jetzt den
heute jetzt kommt
okay er hat nur er steht nicht die die
man als machen ist glaub ich so
arbeitsteilig zu der eine angel daher
schlägt und dann schauen sie doch aus
unserem video gesehen wenn die time habe
ich dann meine ich sowohl studenten
arbeitsteilung es klappt doch eh nie
unter den toten sind
das kommt gar nichts
mein gott da ist ja jetzt eine
planwirtschaft junge ich hasse dieses
wort aber wenn die sache aber ganz es
ist 23 uhr abends jeder der jetzt das
spiel ist ja aber die sind weltweit im
dm gegen mich und die machen nichts ich
komme mit 7 1 nach hause
bleiben wir machen nutzen macher von
kurzen das sind wir wieder leute 100
nummer und ja also jetzt 23 uhr noch was
ich bin jetzt noch code wörter volumen
von code wörter hinein was legal ist
leute ob deine muttersprache ausschau
auf tendenziell nach unten
man muss wenn man kompostiert den
kompost öfter drehen also dass man der
wärmt sich auch extrem in der mitte
aufweist kann sich auch tun die
temperaturen bilden und beim
kompostieren musste den kompost öfters
auch mal zwischen den lüften und so beim
kompostieren nutzens beim trecker vor
baltische wieder einer wollen jetzt
einfach alle heute wo 1 hits läuft wenn
ihr wunsch dass die arbeit und die
scherbe und ich bin tot aber dann hatte
ich alle bond nicht sagt ja hacks alter
die stolz auf sein wenn du so wenn der
hundehalter eine aufnahme da hinten
einer auch die alte stadt aber das
kennen wir jetzt nicht so schön wenn ich
schreibe muss schleunigst cool junge
leute schreibt der lebens lose [ __ ]
alter die gäste lassen die leute so viel
aushalten ich muss immer wieder da
ich weiß dass der inhalt von ungefähr
jedem video aber so bin ich heißt und
was nicht gefällt dann schaut mich bitte
trotzdem weil ich die aufmerksamkeit ja
oder nein was eigentlich sagen wollte
ist wahrscheinlich mein kopf
xi zr 21 bisschen aufgestockt leute das
ist usg der wahrscheinlich gesehen dass
ich schon was drin hast du hast was mit
dass ich länger als bei am besten
wunderschön wieder angelegt also dass
selbst eine atommacht
doch jetzt denken der aufgesammelten
gibt dem ok filter geschenke ich war
einfach geil es so in meinem film ohne
witz allradtechnik gekillt habe kommt
kommt so langsam so die erkenntnisse
mein kopf ewiger du nimmst grad auf und
ich war von dem ganz anderen modus
überhaupt last.fm dass sie weist in der
fans kam zurück wetten ich habe wieder
so gemacht sie immer oh ja quasi wir
untermalen das jetzt musikalisch
danke danke danke applaus
bitte bitte
ich sag ich das war die knappste
entscheidung meines lebens ich sag's
euch alte jungs das oft genommen in
zeitlupe eben sprung gibt der ihm hielt
er stört kriegt den ball herunter was
wisst ihr was ich hatte einfach ein
halbes herz welche auf geschmeidig
gestorben
so hatten sie länger in der luft
gekriegt jung oder alt das war dass alle
kassen ikone wird zwar die krasseste
entscheidung meines lebens
das ist schon ein paar leute es war ich
zwei runden ich hab irgendwann ob ein
kurs geht über den dort spielt spielt
also leute mir gefallen was gerne daumen
nach oben da wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder rein was gut und schaue
lieber eine betreibung abgecheckt habe
die heißen logo und danach bis zum ist